nous sommes en italie
aujourd'hui et plus particulièrement à
naples il flotte dans l'air des refrains
quelle est la cause nationale et pour
faire cette cuisine napolitaine avouer
que j'ai eu de la chance j'ai rencontré
gratte ciel ça ne s'invente pas
gredy elle nous allons faire quoi
aujourd'hui et boulettes de viande qui
sera comme poser avant les boulettes il
faut faire le sa get sa en espagne est
hissé la phase la nourriture qui serait
composée de boulettes de viande du boeuf
du porc du boeuf dulgheru et des raisins
de corinthe des pignons de pin de l'ail
et du persil de confort et de lausanne
et de lui tous alors nous allons faire
partir tout d'abord notre eau faut faire
bouillir ne pas trop faire cuire voilà
on appuie et c'est magnifique ça marche
pas alors nous faisons quoi passer après
ça nous préparons notre ch4 ça comment
on se prépare notre source du salon la
chaîne dounia alors quand je vous dis
que nous nous c'est surtout moi pour le
mic et voilà c'est ça l'oignon on est la
dame pour agir parce qu'on attend d'un
soit rapide des trois gousses d'ail et
ensuite nous décernons nous atrium trois
fois à une fois plié trois fois c'est
pas demain ça marche pas trois fois ça
marche
on va voir si ça marche et ça a marché
hong kong bonn ah oui franchement ça va
pas
c'était alors on va sortir ça bah voilà
qu'est ce qu'on fait alors un nombre de
méthodes à l'om c'est tout il fallait
comme le petit matin la neige était lui
d'abord mettez le hilo d'amour voir le
corps et d'âme encore et encore voilà
très bien au bac et on me sort là de
deux plaintes et hahn bin hassan un
produit tout ça me donnez moi parce
qu'il faut que je fasse quelque chose
oui mais tout le monde que ça veut dire
quelque chose comme ça ma prison puis
nous préparons nous boulettes de viande
boulettes de viande alors il vous faut
quoi un saladier
il faut laisser le dire alors 300 g de
porc et voilà c'est bien ça c'est le
buzz je suis sam de ces deux jeux sont
maintenant je prends tout de même quand
j'entendrai après nos agents de l'ail et
du persil haché avec c'est un fait ça
paraît compliqué pour préparer à voir
4,4 au cou ses barbouzes l'ail le persil
faudra bien qu'il faut lever la ville a
été la bnp a été très bien je me sens
bien ça fait du mieux qu'on a fait ça
marche pas je me sens mais tout ça vous
couvrez et vous le faites
rappaz
je n'occupe
alors vous ajoutez votre âge et votre
perso je met un peu la fête
voilà c'est mon boulot face à la moyenne
des six nations
[Musique]
vous mettez votre prêt à les punir de
plainte est spécieuse à définir une bien
belle saison les mignonnes de feng
directeur qu'on lève de pignan
allez on enlève la lapine de paix vous
expliquez vous font parler ben quoi
c'est ça voilà c'est bien
après on met un peu voilà ça suffit vous
voyez à peu près une poignée nous
première depuis lyon 9 heures une
poignée de résine de koren que ce sont
des dessins de flammes étaient encore
une bonne étoile
une bonne manière de l'école ont dit
voilà je remue tout ça est atteinte à
personne mais après qu'est ce qu'on peut
voir ici ça brûle auparavant dans un
bruit voilà le fromage c'est du parmesan
du parmesan râpé
athaner doucement on va voir combien on
en met on peut conduire la neige le
magnifique pour un combat ira ça ira
très bien ils sont en forme et si le
brillant c'est le vrai se voit par là ne
parle pas de secret dans les cuves il
faut prendre les bons ingrédients pour
que ce soit à bord moi c'est pas bon
alors je remets tout ça ça
très bien mas en soit l'année alors
écoutez je vais passer du terme à mes
tomates métal devient alors là vous
prenez des tomates pendant longtemps à
moi te dire que je vais pas renier des
mecs
voilà qui n'est pas très bien et
qu'est-ce que je fais là j'ai ouvert
s'adaptant du chemin
seulement voilà je me serais même pas
peur voilà le passé à la moulinette
pendant que vous me passez vous le
passez vous mais voilà c'est ça
s'annonce mal que ça et ça n'arrive pas
vous mettez ça dans l'évier laval dans
la pile comme on dit ici
voilà voilà et vous ajoutez une petite
boîte de concentré de tomate une boîte
de concentré de tomates crues mais pas
voulu arrêter ça non mais là je ne me
situe pas là dessus oui une petite boîte
de concentré de tomate oui mais voilà
enfin vous allez vous poivré salé la
maudite
regardez regardez gabriel vous mettez
pas un petit morceau de sucre vous avec
la cicrane aussi comme en iran c'est une
graine de sucre un peu de poids un peu
de patrons ne peut pas c'est pour
enlever la cité de la tomate en conserve
des pèches s'est produit voilà là il ya
un bon feu de joie
et alors après ensuite nous ajouter
votre rôle important dans sa conception
si vous ajoutez m'approche moines dans
un endroit on ajoute à la semoy
[Musique]
on a non seulement alors ensuite life
alors mais bolat des boulettes de viande
à peu près qu'elle fasse 50 grammes par
personne
il faut après cannes et 6 kw à 6 oui et
non il ya un principe à sanaa m ça va
voilà comment ça voyez vous les en
farine et bien vous attendez que votre
cul de four chaud de données voyez pas
ce qu'est ce que ma boîte est belle très
bien très bien ça y est ça y est cette
fois ci c'est bien parti oui je crois
que c'est parce échoué
non mais là c'est parti bien voilà
à la surface mais ça on tombe on va
attendre tout ça s'épuise
mais quand on peut
verdier je crois que c'est cuit les
boulettes sont clairement les maîtres
les odeurs serait formidable intérêt
mais mais c'est déjà pas rien
cet appétit siens d'être à naples ainsi
que c'est bon et falling down la partie
alors voilà mon nom mais ce courrier le
laisser cuire à une bannière petit sauf
équitable
on va attendre une heure d'horloge de
joindre les deux bouts comme celle qu il
ne faut pas de tourner avec une autre
que hier le site où on danse a lu
natation en galice à la casse a varié
mais je crois que tout est pour le mieux
les pattes de votre culture est mis il
ya environ environ 10 minutes limite je
pense qu'elles sont cuites mais les
pâtes à l'eau bouillante bien entendu
pas plus de dix minutes
al dente exactement ceci n'est toujours
pas
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on me permet l'ascenseur
déjà claude il faut intervenir
voilà je lui sors je ne sommes pas
écoutés
[Musique]
tenez je remets ça me va très bien
bon même assez rare mais la science par
dessus donc c'est ça qu'on fait mais
tant de personnes et en place ça tu vas
fête fête fête la plaie voilà ça suffit
[Musique]
mais qu'est la france je vais même aller
jusqu'à les remuer je m'étais pas
d'abord la météo est assez de ça il n'y
a pas besoin de vous expliquer longtemps
c'est choquant c'est sûr mais si beau si
vous voulez cette recette
bien entendu vous écrivez aussi un jeu
de votre station régionale fr3 on l'a
fait pape est difficile que ça à votre
santé vont habiter à votre salon
[Musique]